Speaker 1: Sarah Palin, former Alaska governor and
28 vice presidential nominee for the Republicans,
she is running for Congress, as we
know. She's trying to make a comeback
into public life after a long hiatus. And she is
now past the first hurdle for getting the job.
This is actually a special election
that's going on in Alaska since Don Young
died earlier this year after representing
the at large district in Alaska for 49 years.
Now, Alaska has this interesting system where they
have all of their candidates, regardless of party,
appear on the same ballot for a first round of
voting. The top four vote getters then move on
to the next round of voting, where ranked choice
voting is used to determine who comes out on top.
We just had the first round of voting and we're
still getting the votes in. But as of now,
the results show that Palin has 29.8% of the
vote, followed by another Republican named
Nick Begich at 19.3%. Then we have Al GROSS at
12.5% and Democrat Mary Pallotta at 7.5%. So
those should be the four who advance and move on
to the second round. Notably, not making the cut
yet still getting an impressive 4.5% of the vote
was Democratic Socialist candidate Santa Claus,
which I didn't realize that Santa lived up
in Alaska. I thought he lived up in Canada
or like maybe the international territory that
makes up the North Pole. But apparently he's in
Alaska. RESIDENT And who knows, maybe he'll get
them next time. Palin's near 30% in the vote is
a commanding lead ahead of everyone else. But then
when you note that there's something like 50 other
candidates, you have to think about how the other
voters are going to coalesce when the candidate
number drops down to four. Also, you have ranked
choice voting, so that makes it a little bit
harder to predict compared to a normal election.
So who knows what will happen in the second round.
You just don't know who people are
going to coalesce around. Maybe the
other Republican will do better in the second
round. Maybe the independent Al GROSS will win.
There's a good chance that maybe she's not able
to pull this thing off. And that would, of course,
be a major blow to Trump's endorsement record and
to the state of Trumpism in this country. Because
not only is Palin endorsed by Trump, she and a
lot of ways with Trump before Trump was Trump,
notably based on how incompetent and inarticulate
she was. And we didn't realize that someone so
unqualified could serve in public office at such
a high level. But, you know, then we got Donald
Trump and now it's somewhat normalized. Also,
not helping Palin and Trump is the fact that
Alaska politics are a lot different than the rest
of the country. They tend to be more centrist and
they like the more reasonable candidates more
often than not. So who knows if she can pull it
off there? It's really just not the reddest state
in the country. Plus, many Alaskans view Palin as
a quitter because she quit her job as governor
ten plus years back to do a reality TV show.
So that just didn't sit very well with them. How
do they know that she's not going to resign early
from her seat in Congress? But fear not because
Palin has an excellent excuse in her back pocket
in case she doesn't come out on top. She went on
Mark Levin show a few weeks ago and she said that,
you know, if I don't win, clearly it's because of
voter fraud. Yeah, she's using that routine. Let's
take a look at this clip from about a month ago.
Speaker 3: Yeah. Whether I have a good shot or
not. There, there I think about 50 candidates
in this race. It's a real bizarre race. And
as you say, 50 ballot 50. And Mark, you'll just
really appreciate this. It's mail in only ballots,
no hand counting to tabulate. Got to go through
a Dominion computer to count everything. And by
like yesterday, Mark, I received four ballots in
the mail. I didn't even ask for any ballots. One
for one of the daughters who doesn't live
here. She hasn't haven't cleaned residents
in Alaska since she moved outside. We
call anything outside of Alaska now.
Speaker 2: Trying to say Murkowski.
Speaker 3: Well, you know who wrote this bizarre
election plan that we have right now going on
with the ranked choice voting. That's coming
up. And the mail in ballots and all that
was Lisa murkowski's attorney, I believe
it was. Do I have a shot at it? Yeah, I have a
shot at it. It's it's bizarre, though, you know,
this kind of voting system. So I hope the
rest of America keeps track of what's going
on in Alaska so it doesn't happen to them.
Speaker 1: Well, that's certainly the Trumpian
playbook right there. If you win, everything was
on the up and up and you just got more votes from
the good people of your district or your state.
But if you lose, you didn't really lose. It was
just rigged. And what can you do? You were a
victim, so that's nice. You have that in your
back pocket as an excuse and you can really use
it in any election that you want to. Of course
I want Palin to be defeated and there's really a
good chance of that happening. We'll have to see.
It's going to be tight. But maybe this is a race
that we can get ourselves involved in. But part
of me wonders, like, if Sarah Palin does become
a congressperson, would that have entertainment
value? Would she have these wacky off the rails
speeches on the House floor that would be worth
watching. I also wonder if she would interact well
with people like Marjorie Taylor GREENE and Lauren
Boebert would she be too crazy for them? Would
they be too crazy for her? I just don't know. So,
you know, if she does end up pulling off the win
in this race, that will be like the one saving
grace. We get to see how she functions as a member
of Congress, but hopefully it doesn't get to that.
And hopefully Sarah Palin is defeated when
it's time for the second round of voting.
Of course, there'll be more elections to
come and we'll be following all of them.
All right. Thanks very much to David for
allowing me to host today's show. And if
you want to check out the bonus show, make sure
to become a member at join Packman dot com or go
to Patriot Tor.com slash David Pakman show and
contribute at the $5 level. I'll see you there.